[Music]
you know we talk a lot about the nature
of reality and only human beings we are
a curious bunch right we want to like
look up God's skirt and increasingly you
know through either our understanding of
quantum mechanics and all kinds of new
exotic technologies that are allowing us
to peer at the primary building blocks
of matter for whatever reason we're
starting to find some really weird stuff
you know Buckminster Fuller perhaps had
it right when he said God is a verb you
know there's an amazing amazing article
like Kevin Kelly called the fifth and
sixth discontinuities where he
essentially talks about a series of
discontinuities that have transformed
the context within which we understand
ourselves in the world right so we used
to think the earth was flat we used to
think the earth was the center of the
universe we used to think you know all
these like the erroneous consensus
realities that we had agreed upon that
were smashed by science transforming the
way we understood ourselves we used to
think we were separate from the other
animals and then we realized that we
were descended from apes you know and
and then it just keeps getting weirder
and weirder because now we're at the
point that through quantum physics
through things like nanotechnology what
we're starting to understand is that at
the most primary level reality matter
actually seems like it's made up of
information okay
like John Archibald wheeler the quantum
physicists used to say that it comes
from bit okay bits as in bits of
computer data like data comes before
matter description precedes it miss
writes the verbs are verb being all by
themselves without a need to introduce
nouns I believe was the quote this idea
that matter acts but there are no actors
acting upon the action the verbs are
verbing all by themselves without a need
to introduce
everything is signal everything is
information perhaps there lies the
mystery of consciousness you know but I
just think it's a fascinating idea
[Music]